Speaker 1: Let's now look at around around the
country, so to speak, a tour of right wing media
reactions, more reactions to Joe Biden's COVID
diagnosis. We will start with Oann. This is one
America news anchor Allison Steinberg
gleefully reporting that President Joe
Biden has COVID and asking her followers to
weigh in, to predict, is he going to die?
Speaker 2: Well, what do you know? Double
back, double. And Biden just got COVID.
What do you think's going to happen when we come
back? So glad he got a shot. Could have been much
worse. Or do you think he's going to?
Speaker 1: Your doctor. Yeah. When she says,
do you think he's gonna she does kind of like
the next slice motion. I don't know if that's
some kind of strange filter, by the way, on
this individual. Unclear. So that's an omen.
Allison Steinberg, gleeful about it. Then we go
over to Newsmax, where a Newsmax guest wishes
Biden the best. But. But I wish him the best.
Speaker 2: But so, again, speedy recovery. We
wish him the best. But I think it's time that
we really refocus on some of the issues that we
have here at home and in our backyards
before we go down the path of another
double booster. And vaccines for kids under five.
Speaker 1: Aren't those issues in our backyard?
Like, that's very strange. We should focus on
domestic issues rather than things like whether
Americans get COVID in America. Sounds like a
domestic issue, ma'am. We I wish him the best,
but I'm against racism. But I'm against
the N-word. But. And then on Fox News,
here's another idea. Joe Biden actually had
COVID last Friday when he was in Jerusalem or
as Donald Trump used to call it, Saroo Shalom.
And that this is Harris Faulkner's idea.
Speaker 2: COVID. I'm Harris Faulkner. You were
in the Faulkner Focus. The White House has said
that he is experiencing what they are calling mild
symptoms. He's now in isolation. The president has
referenced his health during his recent visit to
Jerusalem, in his own words. Let's watch. Right.
I was making a speech and I had a terrible head
of hair. Excuse me. A terrible headache. And.
Sorry. I had a terrible headache six
years ago, and I did a very stupid thing.
So again, the president struggling a bit
there. We do know the White House doctors,
the White House has announced that they do not
believe his symptoms from COVID began before
yesterday. That was last Friday, what
we showed you. Just for perspective.
Speaker 1: That's perspective in the Faulkner.
Focus on Fox News. I mean, listen, the timing
of it suggests that he probably didn't have COVID
last Friday. I'm guessing that with a cough like
that, he would be tested. It doesn't really make
sense. The timing of it doesn't really make sense.
By the way, it does bear mentioning that we
know Donald Trump knew he had COVID during
that presidential debate with Joe Biden and he
found a way to not have to test at the venue to
just show up and say, I had a negative test. And
that's crazy. That's completely and totally nuts.
So there was no mention of that by Fox News
at the time. But here's a story that they will
gladly speculate on, even if it doesn't really
make too much sense. So basically, as expected,
reporting on Biden's COVID diagnosis anti-vaxx
glee. Speculation about whether he will die.
Conspiracies about karma and pretending to have
cancer. Just about everything you could imagine.
We have the next David Pakman Show Viewer Townhall
coming up Tuesday, July 26th at 6 p.m. Eastern.
Everyone is welcome to call in. We will open
the phone lines via discord and I will just
take questions, question after question after
question. It will be streaming live on the Pacman
Live YouTube channel. That's the other YouTube
channel, YouTube.com slash Pacman life. I hope
you'll be there. And I also hope that you'll sign
up at join Pacman dot com and become a member.
When you are a member, you get a priority phone
line to call in to the town halls, which is,
I would say, a beautiful thing.
You can use the coupon code Obama.
Speaker 3: Now Obama.
Speaker 1:
To get a discount off of your membership at
join Pacman dot com. We'll take a quick break.
Great to see you here on this
Friday show. The David Pakman Show
is a community funded program you can sign up at.
Join Pack Mint.com. It's the place to do it and
you can use the coupon code. Big voting 22 for a
discount off of the cost of a membership. You'll,
of course, get the world famous award winning
bonus show. I believe the top David Pakman
show bonus show probably in the world and so many
other great things. Sign up. Join pacman dot com